all right date sales time you this is
going to be a fun one I love what I have
a guy in a girl because I feel like I
get a little bit of everybody's
perspective by the way what did you
think of that that mattress read I did
did you think that was pretty solid did
you like that ad you did it in one take
and it sounded amazing to me I couldn't
have done it that well I'm a big fan of
mattresses
you know just in just like I have a
mattress I like a good mat like who you
can't have a shitty mattress no it's
what you spend eat right one for your
life one 30-year life one for the maybe
1/4 of your life if you're an alcoholic
just hours in a day and you sleep eight
hours that's one third it's a third of
your life yeah it wasn't it for three
sleeps eight hours Oh like how much do
you sleep I do try to get eight hours
I'm not going to lie
do I like I need a certain I need at
least seven to function like if I
consistently get under seven hours I'll
get sick I like literally like feel like
I have a cold
interesting you should go to get an
immunity boost at the Jamba Juice over
there probably good idea do you get the
whole seven hours in one session because
I kind of sleep like five and then I try
to sneak in like a nap during the day
sometimes I love naps that I don't
really do them so I do need to do like a
solid seven because I don't do the
napping do you use anything to help you
sleep I can't sleep no but I am a
sensitive sleeper so I actually sleep
with earplugs in so I can't like do
sound at all but I don't do like I don't
like take anything guys that date me
wear earplugs all the time I'm in or not
just at night just all day oh my they
just want anyone over when you're yeah
yeah any time I come over at one sec
babe and they put the earplugs in and so
that's why relationships for me they
last longer than average
I think cuz no one will can hear me I
have a sound machine in my room that
somebody bought me really yeah it just
sounds like a fan sort of like it's just
like a little box you hit it when you go
to bed it's like like a whirring sound
yeah
and that helps you sleep you enjoy the
fan sound you know what I don't turn it
on to sleep but once I'm falling asleep
I switch it on and it keeps me asleep
better I think hey guys you know what I
have an Amazon Alexa and I only use it
this is so funny I didn't buy it was a
gift which I love mom thank you but I
only really use it as an alarm clock to
play music and to sleep I use it as like
a sound machine like I'll go Alexa play
ocean sound and then she does but what's
really funny about it is sometimes she
thinks you're talking to her when you're
not like I'll be on someone on
speakerphone and they'll say something
close to Alexa like exit at or something
and then she'll wake up and start
talking and a couple of times it scared
the [ __ ] out of me because I'll be alone
in my apartment
I'll be watching a show someone on the
show be name like Alex and then they'll
be like Alex and then she'll be like
hello how can I like just say something
from the other room I'm like [ __ ] I have
my Xbox set up so if you say Xbox on
it'll turn the TV on the amp on the
cable box on I can shoot signals
everywhere
I'll do the Kinect and like if it hears
something that sounds like Xbox on all
this on the TVs playing real it's the
same thing
I think I'm crazy because sometimes when
I'm bored at home alone I'll try to have
conversations with Alexa just to see
what's on sexiness well yeah what's so
funny though it's you know she has a
girls voice I'm convinced that she's a
man because if you say Alexa I love you
she'll go oh that's nice thank you like
she'll never say I love you too if you
say we're dissing I've done that to see
you is similar really yeah she'll be
like I'm glad you feel that way about me
or something like you know I don't have
the capability of that or just something
weird like there's all these sorts of
responses they give you I get angry I
like so one day I kept trying to get her
to say oh go Alexa tell me I'm beautiful
and she would be like I am NOT
programmed to give you that information
like some dumb [ __ ] she wouldn't say
anything nice to me right so she won't
say anything nice it but if you say
Alexa add cocaine to my shopping list
she'll go no problem cocaine have been
added you're like it's crazy
Alexa the plug you like she like
I got you on that one Julius guys my
guests today are both fantastic i I've
had one of them on before and I asked
him back because I thought that your
stories were so funny and you date more
than anyone I know I mean this
[ __ ] every time I see him he's
dated like four more girls and by the
way the text you send me that women send
to you make me feel sane and that's part
of our friendship is that I really I
really value it makes me feel normal
alright sometimes I wonder like I feel
like when I send my friends things they
get annoying I love it my friends like
they're all married they don't want to
see that [ __ ] you know I love it I'm
curious now what text messages
oh my god we're going to talk about it
but what comedian Brian monarch everyone
Brian monarch and I have the gorgeous
and talented I met you because I an anti
cuddling public service campaign and how
if you don't love a girl you shouldn't
cuddle her and if you're doing that I
would like to stab you in the dick but
anyway so I I was asking around like
who's a great actress who's funny and
has great timing and like three guys
while I keep adding it up Cheryl she's
so great and now I love all the videos
you make you make hilarious videos and
of course your photos are amazing
because you're stunning so everyone
charelle Patrese thank you for having me
worse I love that you showed up by the
way so glammed-out I can't wear eye
makeup today I almost came here on a
pirate eye patch
oh no yeah because I was walking down
the street yesterday and some [ __ ] just
blew I was walking by a construction
site and by the way no one cat called me
which I am offended by but something hot
by the way thank you putting that out
like I see your pictures on Instagram
and I'm like this is bad well that's a
lot of social media going around you
know like saying catcalling is bad maybe
they're just learning I always
appreciate a good cat call it doesn't
mean I'm going to come for you not when
you're driving by though I don't like
the car well right it's sleazy
yeah but if it's a construction guy
delay hey baby I'm back at last I'm like
hey
is how you judge like oh I so got it
like I'm alright look good today it's
like I meet that little bit of like
confirmation you know I think it is I
think cat calls in your 20s are annoying
any attention in your 30s you're like
thank God like that's it I'm so grateful
that anyone still looking but anyway I
got something in my eye yesterday flew
in it was like a piece of birch or some
[ __ ] I don't know what it was but I
could not open my eye and I was walking
into the nail salon and so I walk at a
nail salon my tears just streaming down
my face and everyone there knows me
because I go there all the time they're
like what's what's wrong what did he do
now they all assumed as a guy like no
there's something in my eyes so I went
home and had a really hot date last
night that was so excited about it a
cancelling I had to cancel my show I was
supposed to be the haha I to cancel
everything I was in your I know well I
think it was just a piece of like maybe
a little tiny piece of gravel or wood or
something but I think it scratched my
eyeball and I've had that happen once
before and so like when that happens
it's just your eye just kind of swells
up or and you can't stuck in there
probably yeah it might have any no
saying yeah like things are like normal
like it doesn't look Iancu yeah that was
Matic I experienced it wasn't weird
because I could see it the green part of
my I had like a little white light
almost like it looked like a scrape on
it or something and I so I have luckily
I have this stuff in my house from the
last time I had and I incident a
sex-related eye injury so I happen to
have this solution to flush out your eye
so I flushed it all night and I just
laid up like a loser amsr-e eyes was
that a sex-related eye injury oh yeah I
got one month have you ever had a sexual
ated eye injury no I got something stuck
in your eye and like what didn't poke me
but I I talked about this on stage but
like I hooked up with this guy
and he was like I wanna come on your
face oh god you're re and it did great
in my eyes it was like he was aiming
football because I closed my eyes
yeah that's happy
and I thought you meant to me no nothing
to me oh you've done that to a chick or
got in her eyes dude it's not so bad for
your eye it turns out did you know that
you can get like STDs in your eyeball my
god no I did not know that yeah it's
really bad my eye got real real enflamed
and I couldn't drive and then I was on
my way to a meeting and when the Sun hit
my eye started to flare up and I had to
go to the emergency room and I doctor at
the emergency room that's what happened
well this is just great condoms aren't
bad enough now we gotta start wearing
goggles well I didn't want to lie on the
juice I like I did okay I came in my
house yeah because I was like what if
what if you know I don't know why needs
to know I don't know I lie you know what
if you can get a std in your eye and it
turns out the doctor goes hey it's very
common and you can get STDs in your eyes
so they actually had to run like so I
don't know how they even did it they ran
some kind of like STD panel on my
eyeball I'm glad you don't have AI
syphilis and I I is not pregnant guys so
that's good that's good there this is a
great opening good story anyway so
enough about me and my eye injury the
point is I'm not wearing eye makeup
today because I can't so what I'm saying
right gorgeous
so guys know they help you so what's up
with you two
first of all Brian yes sends me the
craziest I mean I almost want to open up
the text thread from you and just start
reading view toy I would encourage you
can we talk about the girl here's the
first one okay can we talk about the
girl that was texting you saying um by
the way I would think a guy would love
this this girl's texting him they took
it up was saying like how she wants him
to get naughtier with her like what was
she saying you want to read it or just
tell her which one that is you want she
likes dirty talker some shoot no she's
like I want you to like [ __ ] me in all
these different places and I want you to
be like rough with me and I want you to
like come in my eye I want you to come
in my eye and then drive me to the
emergency room know what I wish I look
in your eye should have called up this
technique I'm ready to go with it
basically
she wants him to go all like oh she said
she wanted to dress up in costumes and
do like role-playing and he totally shut
the [ __ ] down I'm not into that stuff
let me tell you something real fast
maybe I'm playing Jane dude I don't know
I don't like sex bags there's nothing
I'm saying what the sexes match what
they bring over like a bag and it's got
like it's like it what you get in a
gifting suite when you go to like a
party for an extra some girls try get
extra creative and she brings over a bag
and it's got like a porn in it and some
blindfolds and some cuffs some like
poofy handcuffs and like some gel that
tastes like strawberry I don't want any
of that [ __ ] around me why I just want
you to be naked I don't want lingerie I
just that's just not my thing
so no like fun stuff you just want like
intercourse bare bones I think we don't
have plenty of fun without that like I
feel like it's just I don't want to
taste all this crappy goop that I can
play with the strawberry group we don't
have to have to put like handcuffs yeah
not furry hand compasses hang-ups in
general you want to go that route you
wouldn't want to like handcuff the girl
and have your way with her and that
hottest while we're having sex
well I get that but I mean there's
something fun to like really I don't
mind being dominant don't get me wrong
but I don't want her to be what's the
word incapacitated what if she hang up
steals incapacitated doesn't that mean
like passed out I don't think so I think
it just means you're not able to do
things okay
maybe you're right I wonder what a
Google this tomorrow but Aaron can you
tell us what incapacitated means while
we're having scoped it does generally
mean passed out yeah I don't I thought
okay you mean restrained you don't want
her to be restrained I don't want her to
be recent all right well I mean I
understand I don't know though but I can
see where she's coming from to like it
makes you feel sexy as a woman right I I
think it's fun I think it sounded like
switch up stuff now I've never had a sex
bag but I put [ __ ] in my purse before
you're like my purse is a full time size
bag ready to go I guess I don't know she
had a supper bags in her pocket horses
run over I better
she brought over a vibrator that was fun
kind of vibrator sweet like a red one
vibrator go like how does what happens
to you I'm surprised I have the stranger
power incapacitated okay fine I don't
know all right well so it I feel like a
housewife if she's like I couldn't
answer the door I was incapacitated like
she was busy but that's not what it
means
it's so hot though when a guy if your
guy ties you up and that is getting you
off and you can't move there's something
really hot about the fact that like
because you know your natural instinct
on the guys getting you off is to move
right so that's all it is it's just like
a combine stuff like that once in a
while I just don't want a whole freakin
party like know whatever cute things we
got to try to use and I think you kind
of like I mean if some couples are into
like the craziness all the time but I
think I grab like here and there like
sometimes you just want to have normal
sex but I think it's fun to keep things
exciting and like throw in I'm not into
goop like the straw egg I also feel like
another guys and girls are a lot
different obviously we you know guys are
from mars women are from venus type of
thing like i feel like girls love
traveling for instance and don't get me
wrong
everyone likes traveling but not like
girls like traveling like i feel like
really yeah guys love to travel think my
friends and i feel like we just you know
it's cool but it's not like the you know
like the we got to do it every few
months some guys though like my ex has
been to like all seven continents and
every time he has a week off he goes to
some other country or jonathan cutting
Jonathan kite every time like his shows
on hiatus whatever he's like never in
the states he's always traveling I love
to travel
yeah really like I really want to find a
guy that I can travel with a lot because
I just want to have sex in like
different country oh that's like now on
my bucket list is like where fun places
internationally I can now have that like
I just yeah kind of on the bucket list
at all so it's like it okay there's
something to vacation sex and like not
just vacation sex but like for instance
I got so hung up on this one guy and I
think it's because the
first time that we hooked up was not in
LA we both live here but we happen to
both be in the same city for work at the
time and so the first time we hooked up
was there and then we were both there
for a couple days so we ended up hanging
out kind of for a few days which makes
you feel very relationshippy when you're
like on that kind of a trip right so it
automatically in my mind like really
fast forwarded Malaysia near me because
I'd be like oh great now she thinks
she's my girl that's really what
happened so we got back to LA and then
he really like kind of pulled away and
wasn't trying to hang and then I started
to be like but I don't get it like he
wanted to be with me the whole time he
kept coming back to see me on that
trigger vacation Bay I was I was I think
I I think I was on vacation slide check
actually I did China one origin in LA
girl eventually I found out he had
another girl back here yeah that's why
that might be why he did that when you
got back well obviously now I know by
the way I loved he just said day can I
just say I feel almost guilty saying
this but um I recently was dating a guy
who was a little older than me like ten
years older and he write me BAE because
I think he was trying to be like yelling
into him but then he had spell it BA why
trying to pee that's funny
your land no I almost I think I wanted
and by the way I wanted so badly compose
a tweet about it and make a joke out of
everybody followed me on I hate when
guys I date follow me on social media
cuz then I can't make fun of them so you
let them do you follow them back um I
don't follow guys I date normally on
Instagram I mean it every once in a
while I will but I find that like it's
funny I was just talking to a girlfriend
last night she called me upset because
her boyfriend who she's been dating for
three no sorry five months she saw him
liking a lot of his exes stuff I
Instagram how do you know when
somebody's liking other people stuff on
instrument you can see that way in the
like you go like not the discover page
but it's like a second page that'll show
you what people are liking and I'll show
you who they follow yeah and and also if
someone you follow is liking like let's
say you like all Dave Chappelle's stuff
and I follow you
but I don't follow Dave then in the
discover page Dave might start popping
up and then if I click on the photo
because I follow you it'll say right
there like Brian monarch like this photo
so it's not hard to notice also if
you're insecure she might be like
looking at his ex-girlfriend's photos or
whatever but yeah also like yeah I
noticed like if we both follow the same
person and you like it it'll say you
know cake you funny like that's what is
that like right like snitching yes
that's what I mean the other gram is
telling on you like you can't low-key
like someone's stuff anymore it's like
no no yeah but why would you also like
if you're in a relationship that if I'm
dating a guy I'm very careful not to do
[ __ ] to online to make him feel insecure
why would you do that
girls like doing that sometimes on
purpose I think I I believe in like not
keeping things separate I mean I have
followed boyfriends and what before but
I don't look just because I feel like
when you look for stuff you're gonna
find it you're going to find stuff
exactly on Facebook sometimes it'll tell
people that you like things also my
cousins like why do you keep liking all
these hoochies picture it sighs yeah
like she's like I'm like what are you
talking about I mean she showed me a
screenshot and it literally just said
Brian just like this photo and it showed
the photo you hope to do that a long
time ago I do know about it so pizza
last week she showed me yeah I think the
post has to be public by that person
yeah no I don't always have to be
published now there's this new thing on
Facebook where you can love a photo or
like it which i think is even funnier
because this girl was like well I'm not
upset when he likes other girls photos
but if you love them like oh like
there's a big difference right there
yeah but that's why I don't I try not to
follow guys that I'm if I'm really into
you i unfollow because I don't want to
get crazy and go down the road of like
who's this girl commenting what you know
what I mean I just don't want to be I'm
already crazy enough without adding that
level of drama yeah basically so what do
you do how do you feel about okay if
you're dating a guy and he has still has
pictures of his ex on his Instagram uh
you believe in the posts in delete
because a lot of people once they're out
of the relationship they'll go through
and they'll like pretend like it never
happened and delete everything I need to
worry about these days I know isn't it I
know crazy yeah but so when I was first
dating this guy out of my mail
marriage we dated for a year and it
bothered me that in his apartment he
still kept a photo of him and his
ex-girlfriend on his fridge for like the
whole time we were dating and I remember
saying something about it he was like
we're still friends it wasn't a bad
breakup we just so I keep it there and
she had a kid and he's like I love the
kid and the kid was in the photo there's
a lot of gray area I think in this
situation yeah it could be a friendship
thing but like when they're like in
couples pictures you know it's a matter
of insecurity you know sometimes you'd
be like why do you have all those photos
of your ex up on your Instagram like
hugging and kissing and [ __ ] like we're
together now and it sort of makes you
feel like you know that's what people
see I don't really expect them to delete
their history though to you I think well
I mean I tend to keep relationships off
of social media I feel like it gets into
a very murky place where nothing ever
good comes from like really broadcasting
something so I tend to just like not put
it out I feel like if you're in my life
the people that are in my life and that
are my friends and my family will know
you're there I don't need the general
public especially since I do like social
media influencers type stuff I don't
think I need random strangers to know
like I could turn into a situation you
know what I do post at all the photos
you can with so many guys that people
just are confused like shootin which one
is she [ __ ] yes that's all of them is
it none of them will get to a point
where your boyfriend will be like why
don't you take put pictures of us on
your Instagram like it's sort of like
why isn't your Facebook saver in a
relationship it's the same thing do you
want your anybody go on Facebook like
that I'm like go and update a status
like it's not happening I'm not going to
be on my facebook relationship status
ever I will never ever do that
never well no I don't have I have two
people that count to the wedding like
yeah you don't have to have any
relationship status on your facebook by
the way it doesn't have to say single or
you can just leave that whole section
off I don't have that on mine at all
guys are looking from the girls
perspective imagine if you're dating
this guy you're head over heels with in
love with and he doesn't change it I
don't know where I go on Facebook enough
I check Facebook maybe like once every
two to three weeks so I really I
wouldn't even notice it he send me a
friend request I probably I could be
wrong a month but I think you guys are
rarity listen I always thought I would
be upset if it said single
but I would be okay if you just took it
off so it knows it knows dad yeah but
this is so funny the other night I
called my mom speaking of posting I post
tons of I do try to post photos with
lots of guys on my social media just so
no one ever knows one thing real fast
yeah what if you change it what if
you're let's say you're dating we're
dating okay
Brian you know well says you're single
thank you it still says you're single
and you're like and I'm like okay I'll
change it and then I change it to
nothing I think most girls be like I
meant change it to a relationship not to
nothing I know it's just like what I'm
saying is just have it be nothing all
along so the conversation never has to
happen all right let me get my facebook
yes this is one of the reason I feel
like just to not even go and to look
through that stuff because it's like I
just feel become so Messing I'm like I
don't really want to have an argument
about whether or not your facebook says
a certain thing like I just mine's gonna
probably still say single I really like
I don't even like to go on Facebook if I
don't have a choice
that's how you two girls our social
media masters though I think the average
girl really thinks about this stuff when
she said well I would agree I would
agree with I have heard that before I
was so into social media there was a guy
was dating it really bothered me that he
never changed his status to in a
relationship back then but that was
before you could have it say nothing
okay now that you have the option of
nothing I provide go with nothing I have
up there but I mean like I took all my
social media I use Facebook for my fan
page so on my family I'm gonna be honest
like I'm gonna be single like I'm a
boring on whatever ring on it is that do
I even if I marry me I want to tell I'm
gonna present on every single my fan
base is oh there's a lot of men if that
helps them like my stuff more than
you're just going to have to get with
the program and that's the illusion that
I'm putting out yeah and also even if
you're with someone there's always the
option to date someone else if that
person ain't treating you right like
turn like my thing is this if you're
with someone who isn't stepping it up
and is not coming correct and isn't
treating you like you're deserve and and
some dude comes along who is like I
would treat you right that another that
like I don't know if I would I mean I've
never treated in my life I'm
a point now though I am not willing to
put up with like one ounce when I sniff
[ __ ] even in a relationship if
you're lying I sniff it out then you
better believe I'm going to give the
next guy a shot I gotta time you were in
a committed relationship like three
years ago actually spent a long time
order for me but here's the thing though
girls don't you don't have to be in a
committed relationship as a woman to be
committed mentally that's the thing yeah
different plenty times I'm [ __ ] one
guy he just doesn't know right but on in
your head you're like well I just
haven't verbalize this but this is what
it is for me yeah I've gotten texts were
they like just so you know you are the
only person I'm sleeping with like that
just so you know I do it like Facebook I
don't say anything like yeah I feel like
no shadows spread 10:43 p.m. oh my god
I'm so glad that guys can't tell when I
read their tone I turn that [ __ ] off I
do have my reader essays on you do I do
because here you can do an individual
now are you going yeah you just go to
their name and you could save turn
receipt right actually you are right I
think it came with OS 10 I'm the worst
at being a [ __ ] to guys like last night
I didn't reply to a guy's text that I'm
into but he's been irritating me
recently so when he hit me up last night
we didn't hit me up when he text me last
night to explain because I kind of
called him out for his recent behavior
and he text me an explanation that
honestly did make sense it was pretty I
was like the past but I was still
[ __ ] annoyed I even had to bring it
up so I didn't answer
that's the worst because that all he's
thinking that night is like she thinks
I'm lying
yeah and then I felt very powerful going
to sleep all my friends of course is
what girls do because of course I
screengrab it and send it's like eight
girlfriend and they're all like you go
girl
don't [ __ ] texting back do not answer
tonight yeah if you want to answer call
me right but yes you got to get a girl
moral support you're like listen and you
have you get the inclination you contact
me yes you give in like good friend
movement my girlfriend was at another
guy's house trying to get laid and she
goes even if we're [ __ ] if you call
I'm going to pick up you are not texting
him back shoot they're so adamant so I
look at that you found a way to fall
asleep you just pull a power-play
- do you sleep like a baby well I didn't
text him back but you know what happened
I woke up this morning I felt so guilty
for not nice to have again this morning
of course I couldn't help myself I'm so
bad as stay now he thought you were on a
date which going to be good ID him think
yeah we're not together let him think it
I didn't answer until this morning at
like 11:30 and then I just kind of like
I'm sorry to hit your back on everybody
you know this is I was kind of irritated
about what Agron is Ammar that was with
this time limit yeah my mom's
illegitimate legitimately he gently I
but same dinner but anyway so I I do I
post a lot of guys but this is so funny
so I went out on date the other night
with a guy I've known for a while and
and he's hot and we had a great date
right so great went yeah um um well our
kids play ya know it's a guy I've been
friends with for a couple years but like
not close friends but like like you know
we'd see each other every once while at
events and stuff but he didn't live very
close so I don't see him often as often
as I probably if he lived closer we
would have already dated do you know
name II asked right but um but recently
we've been hanging out he kind of like
hit me up and basically this is so funny
how guys think so the first night I met
him I was so into him and I was trying
to give him all the signals I was into
him before I met him I saw photos he's
totally my type
trying to give him all the signals that
I'm into him that night and he was into
me too but then one thing led to another
and I was really tired we were at a club
in a group and I was ready to go and he
wasn't so I said I'm going to leave with
this guy because he's getting uber so
I'll see you tomorrow
um and he was like that's cool my cards
down he's paying for the table so he
couldn't leave he's like that's classy
tomorrow so I left with that other guy
nothing happened with that guy but in
his mind he thought I hooked up with
that guy and he thought oh that's weird
she was into me but then she left with
him so it kind of turned him off and so
then we kind of were friends for a while
and then finally like a few months ago
he told me that's why he never stepped
to me because I would always flirt with
him and be like I think I'm in the year
why aren't
asking me outright he finally said that
night I kind of turned me off that you
left with them and I was like nothing
happened we just feel like we knew her
yeah and it was like four of us it
wasn't just the two of us we shared an
uber bachelor hotel and went to bed
nothing happened and I told him that and
once I told him that he's like okay well
then let me take you out to dinner and
we kind of started yeah so we went out
to dinner than I don't really wear today
I don't know if I want to say we're
because people saw it there but like we
go out to dinner the other night and
then and then we went and got drinks a
like a hotel bar and we had the best
time and then sounds like a baller you
paid for the table dude he yeah he can I
talked about
I can't tell his story on here's people
know who he is he's a total he's such a
[ __ ] gentleman I liked when he called
me a lift he called me a lift to come
meet him and a lift home right okay
which by the way he had a room at the W
did not try to hook up with me like I
love when guys like take their time with
that right ray
my sister left pool he called me a look
premier oh no sway come here okay okay
yeah and then I was like a man I wish
you look closer I would come see you and
he goes let me know when you want to
come off and I've sent a car for you
you're like okay he was 60 miles away
he's gonna send a car for me if you lift
premier to come take you out yet right
so I'm like this guy is treating me like
like gold like totally like gold but uh
so I told my mom I told my mom
everything I talked to my mom like I
talk on this podcast I told my mom the
next day I went out with this guy last
night had a really good time so so hot
you know I'm super into him he's cool
get all this my mom goes who is he and I
told her because I don't know who that
is and I said oh you know what look for
I posted a photo of us on my Instagram
and you know I'm in a bikini and he's
standing next to me and she goes a photo
of you and a bikini next to a guy that
could be anyone
ah how many dates have you been on only
two real dates we're really like we've
only only two days where we kissed I
only count them if you kiss sounds like
next time is a big one
nope I'm not going to no I'm taking my
time now we're gonna play cuz we're
friends so I don't want to [ __ ] it up
yeah like if this doesn't work out I
want us to still be friends so
when I like you a lot I wait longer to
[ __ ] you that probably sounds backwards
do you do that it depends it obvious
haha
are you single right now I am single I'm
dating but I'm like not dating anyone
any anyone anyone any good dates lately
any good any hot stories or terrible
date a lot of DM how's your big on
social media is like Jimmy P I don't so
okay actually I posted thirst traps on
Sunday and I did it I was like on a boat
and I was like I was in the beginning I
was like you know and I need to get my
Instagram pop and a little bit like I
haven't both of us are strapped in a
little bit like a piece of budget when I
drop gems and some gem buy gems I mean
my did pretty much all long so I posted
a couple photos and all of a sudden my
demons were like crazy and I was like I
mean it's all pretty much stranger than
than some people that I know and whatnot
but it was just like all of a sudden a
slurry of male attention and I was like
okay well that's I mean it did what I
wanted it worked pretty much it worked I
did what I needed it to do but I don't
know like I mean I'm throwing a piece of
meat and I'm piranha Lake I'm just like
yeah go eat come get it yeah so I mean
I'm dating casually but I did have I
mean I feel like every time I go on a
date I feel like it's a crazy situation
like I feel like I'm constantly like
dating and Ally is like evil I never met
a stranger that DMD you like and went on
a date with him yeah you have a stranger
wait hold on verified stranger or actual
just like follower so the only reason I
met him in person is because it turned
out my cousin knew him and so when he
first DM to me I didn't know that they
knew each other so I have no idea who he
was and I was like hey he's handsome
he's good-looking and I thought he was
like cool and then so we were just
talking to instrument but very casually
and then I was my cousin was in town and
so I was talking to her and so I
mentioned I was like oh this guy like I
specified what he does he does something
very specific and I was like oh but it
might the ends and she was like oh wait
so and so and it was the guy know what
yeah
and she was like oh that's like I know
I've known him for years of her friends
and so then I met him because I was like
oh so when I know that I love and close
to vouching I get it that's how I you
ever date him well no yeah I mean we're
kind is we're kind of dating I don't
know I mean did you ask your cousin if
she ever dated him no no no she never
dated okay I didn't ever hear I think
she wasn't like the first item the first
thing guys brains go to and girls never
even think about that but I didn't think
about that but I think she would have
she would have mentioned I mean we're
very close like we're like sister so I
don't think she would have been likely I
[ __ ] up a couple years ago not like
not mentioned back right you would have
because if that was a case like I would
not have yeah of course
so then I guess we're kind of casually
dating I don't quite know what did he do
what's his deal she says she'll oh
because we can cook so oh you've been
really like lit this is like two weeks
like we met like two weeks ago so
they're always very new and he like
lives between here in another state so
it's perfect
yeah I love that so it won't be up your
ass exactly so but it is new and so it's
like it's one of those things because
like I go through phases where I'm like
celibate and not dating anyone then when
I do day selling I'm [ __ ] incredibly
horny and saying like then I have to try
to like shut down everything in me life
because now he's out of town and I'm
like oh thank god like I don't have to
[ __ ] you like we haven't had sex or
anything but I'm like oh I was getting
to the point that's the worst you guys
kissed oh right we have how was the kiss
was it like crazy chemistry yeah one of
those a little girl foster yeah yeah we
have a lot of so I'm just glad he's out
of town my dates have you been on
we have been on tail two days and two
weeks jinx I'm curious I have a guy
question when you're very like it would
you say he's very into you does it seem
like he's very into honestly he's kind
of hard to read I don't think like I
feel like I haven't heard from him as
much as I would have liked to so I'm
just like cancel I'm not going to try to
play it cool you know like
psychologically they don't want to like
act to death I'm not fine because I
wouldn't knock his ass and like he won't
ever hear from me again like that is
cool you want to go that route like I'm
petty lady can I say something too about
guys that play it cool because this is
what cracks me up
so girls
if I'm with a guy I'm super into if I'm
super into you and you want to hang out
me twice a week I'm not turned off by
that at all if you're hitting me up
every day being like hey how's your day
so great so dope but a lot of times guys
they go I'm going to play cool I don't
want to sink I'm not into her so they
pull back and you know what happens
while you're pulling back some other guy
comes along and shows you more interest
and you end up losing the girl into the
guy that's showing more interest and if
you're really into a girl that's my
question like save me to check right and
I'm not just talking about these chicks
you bang that ode begging you to do role
playing and you're saying no and you're
clearly not that into her or you would
do whatever she wants but that's beside
the point
my question is say you're really into a
girl her personality everything so much
that you don't even mind waiting to
[ __ ] for a while you're just like so
endure how often do you want to see that
girl at the beginning like how much do
you hit her up yeah um if I could tell
she's really into me too like all the
time really yeah I don't have that I
don't do those games I don't think oh
that's so beautiful I do it alright
that's your heart okay do if I don't if
I'm not into them like is as always
somebody who's indeed other person more
and they're not yeah and when that's not
the case you usually end up together
like right and then so and that's kind
of how I feel like I don't know is he's
playing it cool or he's just not that
into me so I go with the route of he's
just not that into me and then instead I
will just pull away and I will not like
invest in it interesting cuz I'm kind of
like I don't want to play games like I'm
just like either we're going to do this
or not either we're feeling each other
and not till you did let's invest in
this or let's not because I'm like I'm
busy I got [ __ ] to do so where are we
and I I'm gonna admit if I go out with a
guy like recently I went out with a guy
on like four or five days and he moved
really slow like so slow that I was
starting to wonder if he was just trying
to be friends have you ever gone out
with a guy a few times and he doesn't
make a move on you and then you start
going like maybe this guy's just like
hanging out at buddy it's like they're
not really I was good oh I'm pretty
judgy like I I'm kind of like like I'm
so like petty and picky and
maybe one of the reasons why I'm single
because I'm kind of just like if I don't
do like we hit it off like within the
first band was like yeah I don't I know
I do this going anywhere I just got this
text today this is a girl used to date
and she wants kids so badly
37 she wanted kids desperately and every
guy she's dating she thinks is potential
and this is what she wrote me today
she's been on a date with this guy for
eight times and they've only kissed
twice Wow
what would well last times that they
kissed did they think so where'd you
kill me she kissed him like after the
third date okay that's weird dad where
are you older old conversation I'm like
this guy doesn't seem to have that much
luck he's either asexual gay or not
integrating scared or she has to teach
him I'm just like he's 45 oh no I wanted
to yeah he's coming after it yeah that's
my theory with chives too like when guys
like I'm bit I've just been so busy I
mean I've been busy but if I'm super
into someone even if it finding an hour
to grab a coffee with them or something
like I find a way absolutely I don't
believe in when people are like I'm just
so busy like no but you know you can
find 10 minutes 20 minutes you haven't a
call you make time for the things you
want to make time yeah someone's
important to you you will make time to
see that person even if it's just a
phone call or FaceTime or just like hey
I'm in your area let's look grab lunch
or something you'll make the time and we
don't make the time and to be asked to
say I'm so busy I've given that excuse
around my own Zoo movie no but then I'll
make time to like go see someone else so
hey whoa space tummy without a warning
oh that's a worse like you that's
something you got a plan especially in
the morning I cute if you're a girl
right you're right I want to be out of
bed too like I just like yeah yeah sure
I think that's a generational thing or
something I used to talk to this guy who
lived in Philly and you would always try
to FaceTime me on his way to practice on
his way to work like get like seven
o'clock in the morning and I'm like
[ __ ] I don't want to pick up my page
7:00 a.m. I'm in bed I've no makeup on
and you're trying to no this is not
happening and let me tell you let me
tell you guys something probably I would
answer my FaceTime if I had amazing skin
and I would have amazing skin if I was
using bio clarity full-time that's right
I have another smaller this week for the
show
the way your skin is amazing I should
give you some samples they sent me they
sent me samples I'm never like a fan of
stuff that honestly I'm very picky about
what I use on my skin
I've been trying out the bio clarity I'm
kind of obsessed with it like today I
barely warning makeup maybe this is you
know you look like you have makeup on so
I thought it was actually your real skin
I have on tinted moisturizer that's it
you look gorgeous
it looks very clear day whatever they
are doing it for see it's the bio
clarity guys this is the deal life is
better when you're confident in your
skin any girl will tell you that it's
crazy actually and bio clarity helps to
reveal the real use so you can take on
you know school work social media
whatever your thing is you do with clear
skin visit the deal it's naturally
calming and cleansing it has green tea
extracts chamomile it actually cools and
soothes your skin I love the feeling of
it it's very cooling and what's great is
bio clarity doesn't use benzoyl peroxide
which causes redness dryness irritation
I hate when my skin is dry back to earth
so it makes you look old I know everyone
wants to look dewy I feel like that's
what it does it makes you dewy bio
clarity combines the power of
prescription-grade salicylic acid and
restorative flora locks a new and unique
ingredient derived from the chlorophyll
which is like the green stuff in plants
basically so it's all natural it reduces
blemishes it improves the overall look
of your skin you guys need to try it out
what's great is that you can go on bio
clarity dot-com if you're a listener of
my show and get your first month for
only 995 with free shipping which saves
you twenty bucks and it has 100%
risk-free money-back guarantee which is
so dope because if you don't like it
send that back that's right guys go on
there use my discount code the discount
code for this one is date and it's bio
clarity calm discount code date I'm
really happy about this I'm obsessed
with my skin I just like I mean working
on camera is like crazy by the way guys
don't understand I don't I'm going to
get you some bio clarity samples too
though are you trying to say I'm just
saying you never are you saying I don't
look doing right now too bad you're very
doing thank you yeah so anyway I'm glad
we got me talk
about that yeah so there's something
that I always ask everybody I mean Brian
I feel like all you do is go on dates I
don't only go on dates I just stand up
sometimes blisters what's your go-to
first date um dinner I don't like this
I'm not a big drinker I don't like
coffee
I feel like if you're at dinner you can
kind of get to know them sometimes you
end up in a bad situation yeah you don't
think dinner too long I think dinner is
too much of a commitment no it's all
right you can girl you're not trying to
get a free meal I mean I like a free
meal but usually I say let's get drinks
an appetizer so I can duck out whenever
I want dinner is a whole drinking an
appetizer than a meal then you know and
I think I'm pretty picky to the point
where I like I can tell like she's worth
taking out to dinner for one day at
least well that's true I used to date
anybody like when I was like in my 20s
like well you'll go out with me let's do
it now it's more like I'm not swiping
right on everybody you know what I mean
like if somebody like that I match up
with it's probably someone I think has
some potential you do all your dating
online no I mean I'm it shows once in a
while Oh audience people yeah I don't do
this at home have you had any horror
stories lately anything terrible um I
met this one girl we were talking and
all she did was post pictures where was
like this area so she had huge boobs
yeah she particularly upwards pictures
and [ __ ] six of them and they were all
just big boobs and good angles and then
she was like I'm gonna want me to come
over and I was like just come right over
she's like yeah I'm like okay and she
came over to my place
oh you never met her never met her you
this has happened multiple times over
the years where are these chicks man I'm
doing online dating since like AOL chat
rooms and like I have some weird
experiences but anyways what we're gonna
ask every time I hear a story about a
girl that just goes to meet a stranger
all I think in my head is like what are
these girls thinking like what if you're
a serial what if you're an axe murderer
or what if you're going to roofie or
rape her or like aren't people afraid I
picked girls up before undated the first
thing I say when they get in the car I
go what if I was crazy
don't say I don't is my annulus free so
I'm willing to take my gesture all about
that free meal
you're sorry I'm male predation I'm like
okay you can only do if it's so crazy
I'm not going to lie
for me our guys really winning with the
premier girl
it changes you I've dated a guy that
like we were over and everywhere would
over it was like the uber like the
high-end one or what it's all Jake I was
like oh here's a whole new like dating
experience not so hot and not too I'm
going to come right back to me so hot
and also this guy not to change the
topic but when he called me the lift
premier I said you want to give me a
lift premier and he goes baby you're
with me your first class every day and I
was like oh my yes okay
well I mean if you express premier
where's my gown my premiere anyway go on
though Side Story real fast yeah dating
this girl for about four or five months
and I used to didn't have a car
I would Buber her from LA to the valley
and back pretty much four or five times
a week
Wow yeah for like two or three months
were you having sex with her everyday
how were they Abraham years okay that's
one's gonna get you everything was fine
and towards once we stopped seeing each
other she gave me a bunch of [ __ ] about
how I use uber pool oh it was fire
underwater girl I was that is not okay
dissing unacceptable explains you're
using her oh nothing you're wrong but
let me explain something what if some
ghetto ass dude was in the car trying to
like seal up on her oh please in
happening 90% of time I don't even pick
somebody else up but you still gave her
the option of like you may be coming to
[ __ ] me with other people like there may
be other people in the car over pulling
you gotta making a way bigger deal about
out well then you know verbally get out
of the car with you you know Nupur
foiling a girl who's going to [ __ ] you
is like taking like a girl tells you
like steak is my favorite food and you
take her to McDonald did you like just
get the burger without the bottle you
let me explain exactly means explain
this is four or five times a week a tour
time drives that's eight or ten drives
per week and they were like either 25 or
895 why didn't you just go to her house
she had a little piece of crap
Department so and you said she didn't
have a car she didn't have a car at all
why are you dating this girl I'm really
high I mean
I am now if a guy I mean I wouldn't even
accept that like you might remind every
time I just said you mind if I ever pull
you this time it's like I would say like
I go look it's I should do you mind if I
not show up this side I'm like my $25 or
not you know she should have said back
like sure I'm not going to shave my legs
out like I'm gonna put in the same
effort I do that's cool oh I get it
though cuz it's like if you're not a
real guy right now you're very irregular
it was just like it was literally going
to be like $400 a week versus like 120
you know it's funny about this by the
way $400 a week it would be cheaper to
buy her car like really that's a car now
I'm just saying I don't know how much
the price is but I'm just saying at
least for a nice little Honda Civic for
200 bucks a month yeah I wanna get like
4 times a week I will round-trip you
work I look like this goodbye Mr Man I
don't this is a situation that most
people aren't in my area is moped even
yeah I'm sure that would have went over
well there's a moped for you come on I
got me a moped a minute I just want to
put it out there on the record that I
would love for a guy to buy me a scooter
I would sell my car tomorrow if a guy
bought me a scooter you are not going to
come to my house / Laurel Canyon five
times yeah I would hell yes I would and
what I've been training be in my
neighborhood with the first governor
even if even if it's raining I would
wear one of those in Iraq I never did it
again to anyone else because it most
people just one or two rides ever like
you're not driving somewhere all this
was every night almost so why don't you
just let her stay there
why do you day what I shoot a job to go
to and I Drive her back well honor I
will give you that at least you're
paying for her she could have been
paying for her own hoover's a lot I mean
a lot of girls wait she never paid about
Renee what you're gonna girls pay for
their own over I don't think that they
should have to but they do know there
are a lot of real feminist there are a
lot of women I'm sorry
there's a problem here's a problem okay
should a girl should a guy pay forever
over all the time well I know I did
maybe not okay you can
you do get some points for that I mean
oh man rides now that is a lot but what
I'm saying is there are men men who will
pay for your uber every time so
therefore the guys that are not paying
for the girls
uber have to compete with the men who
are so I'm just saying if you want the
level of girl the petty Hoover's paid
for and she never complained about it
once until it was over a city and that's
when I really got them oh you must have
some amazing dick by the way because I'm
not over pulling to [ __ ] anybody I do it
every time either it was only yes it was
only not I didn't do it every time
either I did regular uber sometimes
because it was like you know 15 bucks
but like if it was like 25 or like it
was on a surge basically yeah it was I
mean no much cheaper and sometimes she
didn't even pick anyone else up it was
just like no I mean something to do with
every night almost I just love guys that
are super thoughtful this guy this guy
the same that lifts from your guy it
seems like he's winning because I'm
talking about him the most but I'm
dating a few people but like he like I
said I was thinking about coming to see
him tomorrow and he goes oh let me know
what you want in the house and all
somebody sits in out to get whatever
food and drinks you what your daddy
Stover's all cool you're getting out of
superstar all right here's money then
he's obviously well he's really nicely
baffled yeah have if he has an assistant
and this is going out to Payne I'm just
a little dude and of course the girl
that he's beating you got a point
yeah but III date broke guys too and all
I is you are around town that's how you
write for premiere if a broke guy
hoovered me to his place in a regular
uber and when I got there he got us
takeout and we ate in and watch Netflix
I would be just attacking everything
dinner
I'll be just happy if he's really sweet
and great in bed I love it I like I
learned this experience very simple I
learned don't over pool people ever and
I don't do it but this was a situation
where was all the time so anyways you
want to hear about the horrible date yes
yeah so she comes over she just says I'm
gonna make it over there I'm like okay
and then I was like a little worried I
was thinking like this is weird and I
went downstairs and she's like I can't
find parking and she's bitching and
bitching I can't find parking I'm like
okay I'll come down and I'll try to help
you so I think
just gonna leave and go to my friend's
house in Encino and I'm like okay but I
can come down and help you and I could
tell she just didn't she was worried and
I was like why is she worried about this
like who's gonna give up on parking
there's parking a block away like so I
go down there and I see her drive by and
she was nothing like her photos she
stops it finally I go I get in the car
with her to help her find a parking lot
parking spot and right then I knew she
was not coming upstairs there McDonald's
wrappers all over the floor it was not
it was horrible and I just remember
thinking I have to figure out a way to
tell her she's not coming upstairs
because she's not coming upstairs
oh [ __ ] yeah it was a horrible why'd you
even get in the car
because I didn't really see her open the
door look at her and go nice to meet you
but I got in and I go it was basic like
this we drove around for a second you're
right there's no parking I go let's just
go your friends in Encino Wow Larry so
was she like somewhat similar picture I
was like it looks like completely
different very different person oh it's
just a new person that she showed up as
it was not a trial with a nonworking
nightmare so how'd you get rid of her
you just said there's a party I go yeah
you're right there's no parking and I
your friend is right down the street
probably so that's cool oh well let me
have what the dick I was I was just like
sorry whatever that's you know what I
think different fashion ridiculous I
agree I I think that when a girl shows
up looking drastically different than in
her photos it's no different than a guy
lying to you about like what he's
looking for
I mean lies are lies and that's a lie
you know same with a guy if you show up
and you said yours I'm not I don't
really mind I don't mind if you're short
I don't mind what you look like but be
real don't say you're 6 1 if you're 5 6
you know what I mean it's like a needle
I can was to get laid and I think most
guys would probably do it and I was just
like that's not happening here yeah well
yeah I had a guide like all his photos
online had sunglasses on and I didn't I
didn't realize like how big of a hide
sunglasses are because I just assumed we
had still had a normal-looking eyes yeah
and so he was not smiling at any of the
picture so you always had sunglasses on
but from the photos he looked at traffic
attractive and so finally when I met him
we did dinner and like he had like
really bug I looking like kind of sunken
in bug eyes and then he had fully bad
teeth and I was like
now I realize why you didn't smile or
have like your sunglasses off of me
pictures but it really offended because
I felt I had gotten catfished and I kind
of felt like you don't look yeah it was
like I leave feel like if you're gonna
have sunglasses on the reveal should not
be crazy like the reveal should be like
okay maybe if you go down like point
five but you shouldn't jump down from
like a nine to a three like ah hey
that's not fair at least he had two eyes
I think it was it Dean Delray I got the
story about the guy that came up to him
with sunglasses or something he took
them off you have one off no no one I
was like oh yeah well that's I mean
that's a thing just look like you're
right that's it
so wait did you leave what did you do so
now I mean we had dinner we were at a
restaurant so we had Center and we
talked I mean he was great on paper he
was an attorney he made really great
money and drove a jagged feels like he
had all he was tall he actually was so
that was the one part that was true and
so you have these like great kind of
trappings of success and I like the
height but I just felt like that like
the hi haha I know but I just felt like
the physical I was just like I'm diggin
to teeth I'm really into teeth and so
that's one of the things I look for and
I get hung up yeah great we have nice
teeth
oh yeah that was an average I think I
mean like a dog is like yeah like so but
I'm do you have them all they're all
there yeah they're all there they're
straight they look nice so it was like
the opposite so I kind of I just I think
about what I'm kissing you am I going to
be like turned on yeah she always jagged
things I was supposed to go out with
this guy that I thought was so hot and
then he texted me like a couple hours
before the day and he was like just so
you know I'm missing a tooth oh I'm
missing a do it right now cuz whatever
happened but my new teeth are coming in
on whatever day and then in my mind I'm
like is this a test is he trying to see
if I'm gonna cancel because he's missing
a tooth and then I was also like like
I'm doing a kid like I'd rather meet you
with all your teeth it's like I was I
don't want to meet you my first
impression is I'm missing a tooth unless
you're a hockey player and then I
understand why you're missing a tooth
but even hockey players have fake teeth
you know yeah the second time I went on
this one girl her we find
they got to the point where we got her
shirt off and she was didn't even tell
me this is missing a boob no her boobs
look like they had been socked like hey
easy on that listen I I have a lazy boob
let's not get weird about what on a
second I'm not talking about lazy boob
it was black and blue they had a huge
bruise on it that's where I'm going
someone's sucked on it really hard to
know like they're like so without
hounding it like and I asked her what
the [ __ ] happened it was all purple
right here her whole dude like right on
here yeah yeah on both one of them Wow
and it was like she was at some thing it
was like some sort of weird thing where
they were doing one of those things on
her like for like minutes and minute and
I was just like what actually that's
something you should be told ahead of
time kind of thing like yeah I'm okay
you know like when a dominatrix has like
a stick with like a thing at the end
that she hits your butt with so why was
she - she was getting blue pictures of
some sort of weird sex party and they
were hitting her with this thing I loved
it you like hook up with these girls
that go to like these weird sex parties
where they get beat like their chest
beat on but then when they're like I
want you to hand cupping you're like
that's crazy
I don't think Z I just for first X where
your hands are free oh god alright look
and they're important during sex you
guys are like the previous you guys are
like the best pod can do another hour
with you I have another I have to we
have to stop because we're out of before
we stop do either of you guys need an
uber pool hahaha I got you I just want
to say to the guys listening though this
is the thing like you don't just spend a
lot of money you do yes
no you don't my gosh you really don't
like I love dive bars I love like I
don't to go to a bad restaurant but I'm
fine with the place as okay foods it's
not expensive I just want the guy all
you want is guy to make you feel like a
girl that's it so it's like you just
want the guy to like treat you well if
you're broke but you're giving me a lot
of attention like ask me how my day
isn't genuinely caring like if I had
told a guy I was dating
that I [ __ ] up my I yesterday and he
was like actually one of my guy friends
it's like you want me to bring you
anything you need
that kind of [ __ ] goes so much further
than money for me
oh no I go great I mean I'm like being
thoughtful and generous with your time
and energy like that and big just today
I'm sorry
oh that's all I did you go and find a
lot of rich dudes
we have like five more minutes okay guys
running I did have a crazy date story I
fell in a guy with the smallest penis
I've ever seen and it like a micro penis
like it was like the size of my thumb
when it was hard or soft or did you even
get it to the hardpoint
no like when I was like hard no yeah um
like it literally was like thumbs eyes
and like okay he was black and so it was
like really oh my gosh I have a
character on snapchat
I think PC but I do I play a gay guy on
snapchat a lot that's not PC oh I know
yeah flamboyant Giga and I always
complain about guys who have small dicks
that's all I do I go every day that's
not only but I'm a funny yeah dick was a
sudden he was black too in my story I go
the only time you should see a little
black dick as if it's attached to a
little black baby oh I surely agree I'm
a guy saved in my phone as baby dick
because I was so attracted to my so
excited to [ __ ] him had been built up
for two years and when I saw his dick it
was so small and then it was so
disappointing if he couldn't stay hard
and then it just ruined my whole fantasy
of him and I saved him my phone is baby
dick whenever he texts me it comes up
and even though happy see I get gay guys
coming up to me telling me it's
hilarious oh that's good I just got done
this bomb huh so what happened I mean
and so it was like I just I didn't know
what to do like I was just confused like
my whole life chimbure like I just was
like wait because of this one I mean
there is this area all about he was on
it like more medium height but I still
kind of assumed because he was black so
he'd be at least average yeah I assumed
it was going to be at least I'm I really
okay 5 to 6 inches I just thought that
that like at least 5 I was just so
confused and life is is thrown off I
love it you told you in terms that will
fit this by the way I love this charelle
is 5 to 6 inches average I think 4
inches is actually like the American
average X I think she's right no I think
it's like for like 5 5 to 6 was a great
let's ask Google let's ask Google so I
did you have sex with them did you go
down on them what happened what happened
well no it's ok it's like here's a cab
because he kept saying oh he's gonna go
down on you and I was like well okay oh
you don't need your
dick for that so that's basically yeah
ended up happening and then after you're
done you're like bye yeah I mean a sick
time I don't know what do you do with
that yeah I was like uh like I don't
know where you're gonna go but you can't
stay here then he's there to be a black
guy are we sure that lamentations are
high just send him to meet up with
Bryan's chick who showed up with the
Macdonald rappers in the car and match
made in heaven I was just so confused I
was like I don't know what to do with it
I was like I and one the selling point
was him wanting to just go down on me
and he was like that's all I want to do
and I was like okay well it's only my
Charlie all know if I'm not into them I
mean if I made like yeah you might be
able to get me off even if I'm not into
if I close my eyes and really imagine
someone else is doing it but hey I got
you by the way just FYI this is really
funny I just googled I think I googled
average penis size but what pops up
first is average penis size by year like
as if they're changing like average
penis size for 2017 is different but
just FYI the average length of a flaccid
penis see this right off is 3.6 but hard
I mean erect is 5.1 generally we were
both right well I was imagining a
flaccid dick which is sad oh no I was
thinking it's up in Iraq yeah five dis
again I think lasted five point one inch
dick is a big flaccid dick oh because I
like when it's around it's gonna be like
eight nine inches like that's a monster
I think some people are growers and some
people are shows and I don't want
anything over seven inside me seven is
my I like seven a thick healthy seven
eight that's it
nine or anything above that no no go do
porn yeah that's like I like I'm not cut
out for this
listen we have to go I'm bummed you guys
are amazing you both were amazing I'm
totally going to have you both back
again fantastic charelle where can
people find you so everyone can follow
me instagram or twitter at sure al
patrice that's chdr e ll e patr IC e and
i'm also on facebook at the Shirelles
show done facebook on the sure I'll show
ya and Brian monarch you can find me on
Instagram and Twitter at Brian monarch
Bri
mo na r CH and on snapchat I'm at Bryan
s FV like San Fernando Valley and yeah
I'm from the valley you can go watch him
do is gay Snapdragon no oh my god oh
that's okay I have some Instagram the
good ones I put on Instagram all right
all right guys I am at Kate Q funny as
you know I do want to say thank you so
much the people that are supporting the
podcast on patreon it really is making a
huge difference I'd be working at
Chipotle without you guys
not that that's bags I [ __ ] love
Chipotle but anyway thank you make over
pull you some cannoli I'll go with you
go get some girl guys make sure you
check that out is patreon patreon comm
backslash Kate Q funny thank you to my
sponsors today and guys make sure you
keep on listening to date Val's leave a
nice review if you love it and we'll see
you next time bye bye bye you guys